so I've had lots of meditation teachers
and meditation experts on this show I
just said Bob Roth on I've had Sharon
Salzberg people like Dan Harris
Andy Puddicombe who founded headspace
but nobody has suggested that we do a
meditation before the podcast so that's
a first
listening Tom suggested we do a
two-minute meditation before we begin
and that was beautiful man thank you for
that yeah that was that week's good
things I do accept the space we're all
on the same wavelength now we're ready
to go it's uh it's great to see you man
you too we were we were trying to
remember the last time that that we
bumped into each other and I think it
was at the five-year reunion where I had
a brief conversation with you prior to
that it would have been high school
graduation so many many years but I've
kept tabs on you over the years I'm
certainly well up to speed on on
everything that you're doing it's super
impressive and I'm proud of you man it's
really cool to see what you've done with
your life and I'm excited to talk to you
about it but one thing I think you know
usually when I go into these these
podcasts I do a ton of research and I
want to be totally up to speed on
everything and for you I thought you
know what like I know what you're doing
I'd rather just kind of forget about
that and try to have a real conversation
with you and reconnect with you man cool
so I'm glad I like you're here I'm glad
you're here when I did see you at that
five year reunion I do have a vivid
memory of a conversation we had which
was something along the lines of me
asking you what you were up to and it
was the middle of winter it was freezing
out in Washington DC I said what are you
doing and you said I'm living on
Nantucket I was like year-round in the
winter and you're like yeah I'm like
what are you doing there you're like I'm
making juice I have this juice thing
that I'm doing and I remember just
thinking that sounds like the worst idea
I do that you know so the joke is on me
with that and and you know that's
obviously a huge part of your story but
you know I don't know like I I think
it's your lore as part of your lore but
I do I think that any degree that you
thought it was crazy makes sense I'm not
just saying that like first of all how
many people live on Nantucket in the
wintertime yeah for nowadays yeah but
yeah it was trying to serve them like a
summer sort of beverage in the middle of
winter yeah well you know here's the
funny thing like I was thinking I've
followed you as well and I just so
admire like the I don't know the
commitment I don't know if that's the
right word but but health is a very big
part of it right and and I was thinking
you know there's a big part of me that I
feel distant from being in the juice
business I feel distant from that person
I feel distant from that time and and I
don't think of it in terms of you know a
healthy thing right and I'm in what way
well you know if you go back to those
days it was such a the meat let me give
you a story I'm 24 years old
so I'm three years two years out of
college and someone comes up to me and
says hey Tom you're a real entrepreneur
and my first thought was you you
know I and and because I didn't know
what it meant I thought it meant shyster
and you know I tell that story because
that's how different it was back then
yeah the idea I mean now being an
entrepreneur is the equivalent of being
a rock star everybody wants to be a
founder
everyone knows the word yeah everybody's
social media profile says they founded
this or their CEO whatever but back in
you know 92 or whenever it was that you
started this thing and no one was
talking about starting their own
businesses that was kind of a radical
idea back then the idea of being an
entrepreneur what is that well and even
and I still feel that way now
like
when I think about your life I
appreciate which I think is common I
mean I appreciate your what I know of
your life you know your your your
competitiveness your your I don't know
clearly your health some of the things
that you pursue and that's what attracts
me you know I'm not that interested in
your business no offense I'm not I'm
just not that interested in businesses
overall but the idea that you're you
know the things that you do on a daily
basis the things you learn the things
you see it's really interesting to me so
when this person called me an
entrepreneur I legitimately thought no I
I make juice mmm you know and it was
like an offense to me like I don't wanna
I didn't do this to be a business person
well again I thought it was a person on
the take I didn't really actually know
what it meant
sounds corny but it's just that so this
was you know we started in 1989 and I'm
gonna guess this was like 91 or
something like that as you said but a
different time just a very very
different world but you didn't get into
it to create some massive enterprise
like you were just having fun you love
juice you love making juice you would
get in these boats right and ya
hand-deliver them yeah you know home
delivery or whatever yeah and that has
like a there's a romantic veneer to that
yeah you know you know and it's I must
say like kind of deservedly so you know
there came a time let me be clear there
came a time where we knew this was true
mm-hmm that we you know there came a
time where we knew this was an
interesting idea that it was an
interesting story that could sell and
did so but not in the beginning I mean
in the beginning if you remember when we
graduate from college the economy was
terrible
right I couldn't get in an interview I
didn't know what I wanted to do but you
know you go to career services to get
interviews and like my friends would try
to get interviews at goldman sachs i
didn't know what that was like
either i mean people don't understand
that back in that time pre-internet you
would go to your career counselor office
yeah at college like we went to to the
best colleges in the world and there'd
be pamphlets
like Boston Consulting yeah and like I
was like I don't know what that is like
what it didn't seem like there were that
many options and everybody was just
lining up to do interviews at investment
banks and consulting firms and anything
outside of that was either med school or
law school and that's kind of where it
ended yeah no I mean that's so true you
know and I think about like my friends
who would apply like they they wanted to
work it like Merrill Lynch in banking so
I thought they're gonna be bank tellers
mm-hmm fortunately I didn't know I was
like oh you're gonna be the same I still
I moved to New York and lived with three
guys who were analysts at Morgan Stanley
and to this day I have no idea what they
went to work and did all day yeah we and
that is very different I know kids in
high school know what Goldman Sachs is
right we did not know that I mean it was
just a very different world how would
you even know that that would be
something that you would want to do yeah
I don't know I don't know well I mean
you know what it's funny I'm on my
flight tonight or today was um Michael
Douglas mm-hmm that was the only thing
we knew about Wall Street was Wall
Street right the movie thing I knew and
by the way that might not have been out
yet I don't think it was I think that
came later it may maybe it did yeah did
you tell him that no I didn't say we're
doing he didn't want to be bothered
that's really funny well I'm trying to
remember a you told me that you were
just recently back in Washington for
funeral for the wife of Lowell Davis who
was the athletic director of our school
at the time and you know I've been
thinking in kind of wrapping my head
around you know seeing you today like
remembering my high school experience
which I wrote about in my book like you
know I didn't have a good time at landon
like that was not the right place for me
the the culture just was antithetical to
the kind of kid that i was like this
sensitive kid and i tried like i tried
to fit in like i you know i've known you
like my daughter's 14 like i think i was
14 when I met you like I've known you
most of my life yeah and I remember
joining the basketball team in seventh
grade and
was just god-awful you know and I was
appropriately mocked for that and I
remember that you you know you were
somebody who was always you know very
good at sports excelled at school
extremely handsome like you were a
popular kid and your best friend was
Neil Phillips who was in arguably the
best athlete at the school who went on
to Harvard and we can get into his
career in his life because it's
inspiring and we were talking about that
previously somebody who to this day is
still I would I presume is your best
friend
to this day right yeah and the two of
you guys always treated me kindly and
fairly when you didn't have to as sort
of the kingpins of the school when some
of the other kids weren't and and so I
wanted to thank you yeah because I you
know it was it was that was difficult
like seventh eighth ninth grade it's
just really hard years for me and it's
funny because I'm interested in your
recollections of Landon and your your
thoughts on that because when my book
came out like they reached out to me
that I call will you sign a copy of the
book we want to put it in the library I
was like did you read the book like yeah
I didn't exactly paint you know the the
best picture of the school and and
that's something that I've had to kind
of come to terms with and make peace
with over the years like it was what it
was it was fine I got an amazing
education all of that but I think you
know it it damaged me socially and
probably contributed to my alcoholism in
some way and I'm cool with it now and so
I think for you to be sitting across
from me as a very you know it's it's a
symbolic kind of full circle moment for
me to kind of reflect back on that time
so when you think about that period of
your life like what comes to mind yeah
it's funny I didn't know you know I know
the story from the book mm-hmm
and I didn't know most of that honestly
I just maybe I should have paid more
attention I don't know I know I mean
we're just kids I basically I just ended
up kind of withdrawing you know socially
from the school and just got into
someone
that was like my thing well so that was
a tough place you know it was a very
male-dominated athlete dominated place
that um but that nonetheless I still you
know I have a lot of friends from there
I've had an interesting relationship
with it with it over the years but um
but I didn't know you know I what I
didn't to be clear I didn't know how I
might have played a role in the way you
felt I'd never knew and because some of
the names you mentioned at least one
name in the book that is you know a guy
who was a friend of mine I haven't seen
him in years yeah and and I've since I
actually regret calling him out and I've
had communication with him and I have
another version of the book coming out
in a couple weeks and I changed all of
that
you didn't yeah I think that was that
mention came out of resentment you know
and I don't think it was fair to him
so I thought that was inappropriate I
mean it was a pain point from for sure
yeah and I'm sure he's a you know
perfectly nice human being now yeah yeah
I think he is I mean I you know I think
with those kinds of things
did you see wonder I haven't seen that
yeah my daughters have seen a privacy so
I watched it with my kids and and it
effectively it tells the stories from
the different sides where these these
conflicts and there's you know there's a
kid in particular who has a tough time
and I don't know I think of a lot of
those things I mean not you and I have
you know addiction in our past and I
sort of think of some of the challenges
that I've been through in my life and
the way I interpreted certain things and
you know generally speaking it's funny I
had a guy the other day friend me on
Facebook or you know asked me to be his
friend on Facebook and it's a tough one
for me I haven't said yes and and and
it's because my interpretation of our
relationship is really negative like
really really negative
and I don't know in the end sort of how
I feel about that but um but going back
to going back to school I mean I guess
that it's amazing how much the world has
changed and and having been there a
couple of weeks ago so I was back at
land and we're rich and I was high
school and were you and I went high
school and um Neal Phillips smoked and
as I was saying to you earlier you know
Neal runs a school for boys of color
it's a it's a charter school in Florida
and Neal's on the front lines every day
mm-hmm Neal sees it all I think all the
stuff that I can sort of theorize and
sort of look at from afar and read about
and try to understand he deals with on a
daily basis and as a result Annie and
he's running his own school which just
imagine that right a start-up school
with your african-american guy running a
school for underprivileged kids of color
is it all boys boys all boys of color in
Florida in Florida in a very you know
low-income like suburban blight ish kind
of neighborhood and um and they don't
love him you know public schools don't
love charter schools and some of the
community does not like what they're
doing there's a big portion of community
who does love what he's doing and he's
amazing I mean he is just like this is a
guy who whose intentions were always in
a good place but now he practices on a
day to day basis anyway he gave one of
the remembrances of Nancy Davis Nancy
yeah Nancy Davis and it was just
beautiful it was beautiful I mean I
think if you were there you would have
appreciated just here it is how long has
it been 30 years more 32 years yeah 32
years and there's something about a
funeral the thoughts that go into a
funeral and just the time and the
relationships and the people and the
fact that you know we're all in our 50s
now we're not in kids anymore
and I just when Neal was done I thought
like what a special moment like what a
special guy what a special moment yeah
he's very he's a very gifted orator
and like I said to you before the
podcast like I watched his presentation
at the Nantucket project was that last
fall or less yeah yeah yeah I mean it
was very moving and I thought this guy
you know should be speaking all the time
in front of audiences constantly like
he's he's very impactful in his message
in his delivery and and I wish that I
wish that I had been there I think that
would have been a healing moment for me
because I was sort of famously at war
with Lola Davis the whole time that I
was there cuz I just wanted to like a
lot of attention to go swim and he
wouldn't let me and I was like what is
wrong with him no like he didn't like me
I didn't like him and you know here we
are 32 years later like you know let it
go already man you know I never knew
that so he didn't want you going
swimming well what happened was I
started to you know get good at swimming
and I wanted to take it to the next
level and that involved you know joining
a club team that would require me to
work out basically every day from like
you know 3:00 to 5:00 or whatever it was
during the sports period at Landon and
for those that are listening land and
it's just you know it's traditional prep
school in suburban Maryland and like you
said like sports was a big deal there
and they prided themselves on their
mandatory sports program every boy that
goes through land and goes through our
sports program and there was no swim
team and I was like getting really good
at swimming and I wanted to be able to
take the sport as far as I could and
that required me going to Lowell Davis
and saying can you let me out of your
mandatory sports program so I can go
swim for this club and I'm gonna train
like that's what I want to do and he was
like absolutely not you have to go and I
was like come on decide to write this
petition and I had you know I had to
jump through a million hoops and
ultimately he kept shutting me down and
Malcolm Coates who was the headmaster at
the time kind of came to my aid and said
come on man let this guy do you know
this is what he wants to do let him do
it and even Malcolm was like well you
know don't you think you know you need
to learn how to play tennis and you know
what if you're gonna need that in big
house like come on man let me do it and
so he did and I think law was not happy
about that so we were kind of like
chilly around each other for the rest of
the time but
what happened was senior year I wanted
to compete in high school championships
the local high school championships and
in order to do that you need to be a
member of high school in swimming
program landed and I was swim team so I
figured out a way to start one with
Malcolm coats's help and kind of
piggybacked into a field few dual meets
to jump through the hoops that I needed
to to I qualify for this meet and that
was like the little seed you know that
okay well they're technically there's a
swim team at land and now even though I
was the only one who is part of that but
now there's a team you know so it's cool
that now there's a swim team there that
I feel like on some level I helped
initiate but but you know I sort of been
walking around for thirty years like you
know knowing my teeth about little Davis
and so had I been present to see Neil
you know speak in that regard I think
would have been good for me yeah you
know I'm gonna give you my side of your
story which is limited of course but I
know what my side of your story is which
is by the way didn't didn't our team
actually do well our team of one we did
pretty well yeah I mean you were the
only guy on the team in miry I remember
like I remember an announcement that
said something like the such-and-such
competition happened and Landon came in
whatever I think I remember that - I
think Malcolm Coates like he really
liked champion being he like took care
of me like he was fond of me and and and
and that's a that was a precious
relationship for me so he made a point
of like announcing that RC gone well I
think he passed away yeah yeah he passed
away so I got yeah I got second at
metros the guy beat me ended up making
the Olympics so I don't feel so bad
about that yeah but anyway well so I
remember you as very sweet kid very nice
kid really fit kid you know and and like
a star like I was cognizant enough at
that time and I would say we cuz I know
I remember talking to Neil about it that
the fact that you went to swim at
Stanford from Landon was like a miracle
you know that was a big deal
imagine you know
today I doubt many kids make it to
Stanford as swimmers where they don't
even have a high school team although
now it's probably an AAU thing yeah I
mean it's mostly most of those kids come
through club high school anyway
and it's much harder now than it was
then but you know thank you for saying
that well but I but I do also I just
remember you as like a I would have said
happy sweet a little awkward mm-hmm no
definitely awkward basically sleeping
through study hall
you know drooling on my books in the
library and and but I felt I felt apart
from like I think it's that I think it's
it's alcoholism like always feeling like
you don't fit in or you can't relate to
people and I kind of took that and
isolated myself so you know I played a
huge part in separating myself from
everybody else I think at that time as
well have you been back I think I've
driven by it I haven't been on the
campus so maybe I need to do that for my
own sake you know the new headmaster I
think you'd really like a guy named Jim
Neil mm-hmm
I don't want to go into it really but I
had some issues with Landon for a while
and my father you know my father works
there know that yeah and your brother
went to land and my brother would land
and he was on the board for a while yeah
but my father teaches the history of war
and he you know he's been there for I
don't know 10 years Wow
he retired and he now it'll tell teacher
Landon that's amazing
that is crazy you know he's I think he's
80 I should know this he's 80 was about
to turn 81 huh and um he can barely hear
and I don't know how he does it but the
kids love them the kids love them so
that's cool so let's talk about you I
think of you as a storyteller it seems
to be the thing that is the anchor or
the consistent kind of theme that runs
through everything that you've done
since Nantucket nectars whether it was
plum TV
you know the movie projects and
television projects that you've been
associated with and we can get into that
and now what you're doing with an Tucket
project
and then this new podcast is launched as
well but ultimately it boils down to
telling stories and helping other people
tell stories that matter yeah you know
it's funny I was I I've been reading if
you read much Joseph Campbell yeah yeah
so I've had like a reunification with
Joseph Campbell in the last a few months
and then yesterday I watched I watched
finding Joe have you seen that not
haven't seen that it's pretty good you
know it's like a nice Joseph Campbell
survey course and you know this notion
of finding your bliss which you know I
think so much of like the struggles I've
had in my life are built around fear and
I always felt like a fraud academically
you know I can't read very well I know
that sounds crazy but my SATs were
really good except reading comprehension
like you put me on reading comprehension
I read the paragraph or whatever and
then I go to the question so I'm like I
never heard of these people you know I
don't know anything they're asking and
you know to this day it's really hard
for me to read now I just crank through
books audiobooks you know I just I'm
just I got really into audio books as
they kind of flourished over the last a
little bit but I think my bliss might be
curiosity you know I really like to
learn I just love to consume information
in whatever form I do a lot of it by
listening now and in the end I get a
great it's very satisfying when I can
learn something in the chair right so so
yeah I do think in a way storytelling is
a big part of what I do but it's all
driven by curiosity so what was what was
the driving curiosity that led you to
create Nantucket
object you know frustration was a lot of
it I'll say that our world is shallow I
mean we live in a shallow world you know
it's just incredible sort of where we've
come there's a lot that means look
there's a lot to be happy about there's
a lot in many ways the world has
progressed in some really powerful ways
but I would argue that the world is
regressed in a lot of ways as well
and I reached a time I was always
fascinated with the 24-hour news cycle
and when you know MSNBC and CNN and Fox
grew I just I always found it really
fascinating you know and I appreciate it
very much the and I'm all for the free
market you know news game media game um
but I have to say that you know sometime
around ten years ago I just thought this
is getting just crazy really
disappointing and and it's amazing the
things I hear people say to each other
the things people write about each other
and there came a day where I thought you
know what you got to go looking for
yourself you got to go out there and
look for these stories on your own and
work with other people to do that when I
started plum TV the idea was for profit
PBS mm-hmm you know it was this idea
that I bought the television station on
Nantucket kind of on a whim you know
kind of for fun
I'd been I'd been buying media for
Nantucket nectars all those years we
made our own radio ads I did a ton of
radio in those ten years and and we
started doing these mini documentaries
sort of right from the get-go and I just
loved it I loved it and it was amazing
how you know any story I've done that I
love it's all about cooperation it's all
about some other person's willingness
and desire to sort of make something
with you you just can't do it on your
own and and so ultimately it was out of
frustration where I thought you know
what I want to bring people together and
ask them to share in a vulnerable way
things are meaningful and you know every
word I just said is a little bit corny
vulnerable meaningful etc but behind the
corniness it's a real thing you know
it's it's just uh
when you discover those moments when you
really get the sense that this person is
on an edge and they're kind of bringing
you the goods that are that just could
mean so much to your life and so much to
the lives of the people around you
I find it you know it's like a form of
hi I just think it's incredible yeah as
an antidote to the negativity and the
onslaught of just information overload
that has become the defining aspect of
how we kind of sort of normally navigate
our day like we're just inundated with
information now we call it content you
know but what what percentage of that
information is actually bringing us
value or making us more content or more
fulfilled in our lives and and I think
there's a I think there's a need and a
desperation I would go so far as to say
that maybe most people aren't even
consciously aware that they're that
they're starving for and I think that's
one reason why podcasting has now become
a bigger thing it's like oh my god
they're actually like they're not
rushing through this thing they're gonna
they're gonna talk like real people like
I'm not used to that
you know it's not ten people shouting
over each other on a 30 second you know
news piece on cable news that leaves
people frazzled and agitated and and yet
always impulsively coming back for more
yeah you know it's it's so yours I'm not
just saying this like yours is one of
the podcasts I have the closest
relationship with and you know I think
generally it's changing rapidly as you
just pointed out but like I think when
podcasts first started to happen people
thought of them as like you can download
this American Life mm-hmm now I
appreciate this American life I think
it's great but I think of it as a radio
show I mean it's it's a show that has
beats and timing and all these other
things gotta believe well produced and
researched yeah beautiful I I can't say
enough good things about it but the
relationship you develop through a
podcast like yours is I don't even know
what it is you know what do you call
that you know
it's well there's an intimacy to it ya
know I think because it's rough around
the edges and you know I'm not editing
these things or you know it's like you
you get what you get like this is you
know we're gonna sit down we're gonna
talk and at the end of this people are
gonna feel like they know who you are
you know they're getting a very real
sense of who you are as a human being
that's very different from a radio
interview or a television interview
where it's just let's hit these beats
and get the information extract the
wisdom or whatever news item somebody's
looking to get and I think that they're
you know baked into that is this
starvation for something that's real and
authentic and and you know it's like I
hate using that word authentic it's just
it gets it's been devalued because it's
been commodified so much but there's
truth in that yeah well you know it's
it's so I mentioned you know we we
started these journeys go find these
stories go go find these people like
Neil like Neil Phillips you know who are
who it's like that guy needs to have a
spotlight shined on yeah yeah and and
like the thing he did the thing he
brings to your spirit the thing he
brings to my spirit is so powerful now I
also have the advantage which you know
this is the thing we just discovered we
discovered in the last couple years is
that when we were made you know we
started making these stories we do you
know a ted-like kind of gathering but
then we started making films often out
of the talks we do these strange sort of
artistic collaborations that are I would
argue beautiful of different kinds and
it's always sort of stories of meaning
again a term that's not the greatest
term in the world but I don't know a
better one if you got one of them I'd
love to hear it but one of the things
that happened as we started sharing our
stuff in homes people would invite me to
their house a hey would you come over
and play some stuff for us so we started
to do it and then one day I go over to
someone's house i package like 45
minutes of our stuff and we just to
watch because she said we please do this
I said sure I'll do it I didn't really
want to do it quite frankly
for like a group of people or just like
this person who lives in this house she
she said I wanna bring 20 people to my
house and show show them what you do and
so our thing is
it's a it's a combination of talks and
films and art and music so you kind of
sit there and you have this experience
and it's a little weird in a sense but
it's kind of like sitting in a room
doing a two minute meditation before
podcasts it feels a little awkward but
it's powerful it's like a really cool
and interesting thing that again I
thought she just wanted me to show it to
these people and maybe they'd come next
fall to our gathering on Nantucket and
the thing ended the 45-minute film
essentially which was a mix of stuff
that I shared with them and there and
the first woman who spoke was crying and
she said I don't have meaningful
conversations in my life anymore and we
talked for three and a half hours so
then we did it again I dream we know we
remixed it went to the same house with
20 different people same result and you
know apropos of the podcast conversation
it was conversation it's like this
magical thing that animates stories
animates them in the sense that you can
do things with them you know like what
is forgiveness I could read in it a book
but if you and I had a conversation
about forgiveness I can use it I can
take it somewhere else I can experience
it it's like recovery mm-hmm you know
that's beautiful and I think it you know
it does speak to that thirst that hunger
for something real and something
authentic and and I think that we have
you know law like the podcasting and the
work that you're doing is is a
reaffirmation and re-emerge insist art
of conversation that's so baked into our
DNA is something that we need and desire
in order to be fulfilled and as we you
know navigate the you know torrential
waters of social media we feel like
we're more connected than ever but
everything is at an arm's length and
everything is digitized and everything
is immediate and temporal and and sort
of short lasting yeah you know it's like
this fuse that ignites and that's gone
how often like this but you know it's
like this is like the 350th conversation
that I've had on this pocket is like I
get to have these amazing experiences
like if we just went out to launch like
hey I'm in town come and meet me we'd
have lunch it would be cool maybe we
talked for an hour would be awesome but
the formality of this structure allows
us to go deeper in a way that we
wouldn't ordinarily and I guarantee you
when this is concluded like we're gonna
feel connected yeah in a way that you
cannot fabricate any other way no and I
think that that is why people are
responding to the work that you're doing
because we have that deep need for that
connection well and you know the other
part of it too so yesterday I went to a
you know gathering for the camp my kids
go to and I sat next to a teacher at
their school who coincidentally was just
made the something a senior guy at their
camp I don't know what the position is
called guy named Matt dandelo
and and turns out we're both vegans so
he says you know do you have any gurus
says it to me and I said yeah do you and
he said yeah and I said who and he said
rich broad and I said I said this is
yesterday and I said really and I said
you know I'm gonna see him tomorrow and
he said yeah me and five other teachers
at the school listen every week and then
we talk about it now he and I talked
about it for about 45 minutes it was a
real conversation we're like a social
event middle of a day on a Sunday and
and the thing I was going to say is
because there's a I think there's
another really important piece of this
is that you change so yeah we will feel
connected but I will change I will
become a different person and my you
know my ability to ignite a couple weeks
ago my family my you know my brother my
two sisters my mom and my dad we met in
DC right after the funeral what I will
tell you is that we have never met as a
group probably in our lives
you know never all together all together
with no spouse is just us because there
were some issues or some family
we wanted to workout and hour and 15
minutes 20 years of some anxieties
little bit of tensions
you know unknowns boom like boom just
cleared up in totally different scenario
you know my sister in particular one of
my sisters in particular it was very
anxious about a bunch of stuff going on
in the family such a sense of relief so
yeah I mean I think the connection is a
real thing but change I mean it's just
incredible the way so what do you
attribute the that transformation to
like is it because you have a tool box
with what you've learned that you're
able to communicate in a different way
where you can transcend some of these
issues that historically have created
issues or you know I I don't know to
what degree I take any credit for it I I
I do I was just witness to it in this
case but what I will say is I mean I
kind of helped champion in it but it was
really my brother my older brother and
he really led it I was just there to
kind of listen and then and then throw
in where I want to throw in I would say
there was a moment early on in the
conversation where I you know I I was
feeling the tension I said look I just
want you guys to know where I'm coming
from in this and that is that I love you
guys and I want to find an answer here I
don't have one that I know to be the
right one I probably have my own sort of
beliefs but in the end I just want
everyone to be happier and closer I
wouldn't have said that the old me would
have had an agenda and I would have told
everyone how you know brilliantly this
thing could be solved so there are those
kinds of things that I feel like I'm a
different person mm-hmm
but that's recovery right I mean that's
like yeah it's recovery and I think it's
just the messages of all these people
that you've had the privilege of
encountering over the years as a result
of nantucket project and the stuff that
you do that's all kind of just
percolating in your unconscious mind you
know people ask me all the time like
well you call these people and they come
and they tell you all these ways of
living and all of that like how do you
how do you codify that like do you make
lists and then make decisions about it
I'm like no it just is
it's just it's just there it's like this
you know floating thing in my that I'm
not even consciously aware of that I
know profoundly impacts how I behave and
has improved how I how I how I live but
I couldn't tell you oh it was because of
this person or that thing yeah so so
this this these gatherings that we do we
call it the neighborhood project and we
do it in rooms all over the country and
I was in Oakland a couple weeks ago and
it's called the Dunn Meyer project
they're all called a different project
so everyone is named after the town or
whatever or the street or the or
whatever they want and I sat down and it
was one of the participants it was one
of the women who is a member of that
group and she started talking and you
know and it was it was meant to be kind
of an informational conversation I
wanted to kind of learn how their room
was functioning and trying to get
educated on what's working and what is
it
and she went into a story about sexual
abuse and suffice it to say I I was
hanging on every word she said and it
was about sort of abuse and forgiveness
in in this case for grandfather and you
know that one of our lines is you never
know who you're sitting next to and and
she talked about how being part of her
group has opened her up you know
authenticity vulnerability again some of
the terms but and and when I saw what
was happening sort of being with this
woman
I thought because you mentioned well I'm
bringing this up because you mentioned
some of the interesting people that I've
met I've liked you I've met a lot of
really interesting people this woman
wasn't meant to be one of those people
you know this this was just meant to be
like a civilian or whatever term you
want to use and it turns out there like
there are no civilians you know it's
it's like you put someone in the right
frame or they put you in the right frame
it's incredible sort of what comes out I
you know and I think in the end
the good news is you know you like
acceptance how do you find acceptance
how do you practice acceptance well one
of the gifts is just fatigue you've had
enough you know you've had a freaking
tough yeah and in this case I think
we've had enough I think social me is
just let me suffer yeah at some point
you're like I gotta let this go yeah so
what is your what is your relationship
with social media then well I have one
I'm a voyeur you know I watch I I can't
believe it like I cannot believe how
much people will write political stuff
for example and I think like you know
who's the who's the who's the god who
pushes the stone up the hill how I'm
gonna get crucified not having right now
whoever those yeah I feel like an idiot
cuz I can't think of who that is
but it's in it like that mmm I mean have
you ever seen a political battle with a
victorious outcome on social media and
yet people do it all day long and I
watch and I think like wow this is so
interesting it's so interesting you know
one of the things I think about as I go
back to us as kids and I think you know
Neil got to make all the calls cuz he
almost like the leader mm-hmm I mean I'm
making this up but generally speaking
you know to have that kind of a voice it
didn't exist and that I wonder like is
this pent up frustration from I think a
lot of it is I think you know look it's
it's a very different time we grew up in
Washington DC every like we're
surrounded by politicians yet there was
a civility yeah there was an ability to
reach across the aisle and have you know
grown-up conversations with people to
reach consensus there was not the
divisive 'no seeing now and i think it
speaks to you know this undercurrent of
frustration and resentment and anger as
you know the haves and the have-nots
start to split and become you know
further separated and that's a huge
problem that I see only becoming more
exacerbated and so what happens we end
up in our silos and I think when you go
online like I always have this internal
debate
I have strong opinions on certain
political issues and as somebody who has
a platform like what is my
responsibility to talk about this and I
see other people doing it and I have
this sort of twofold reaction to that
like one is well if they're doing it
then I should too and then the second
thought is well I don't have to because
they're doing it and what do I gain or
what is gained in the macro for me
chiming in on a conversation they could
potentially you know make my thoughts
known in a public forum but also create
divisive nacelle aware that it's it
doesn't it doesn't like stating your
opinion on a hot-button issue doesn't
necessarily change hearts and minds you
know we've done a lot of research into
the impact of time spent in the digital
world and and compared it to time spent
in conversation right and I won't bore
you with it but the bottom line is more
time spent in the digital world the more
irritable you are the more depressed you
are the more divided you are people who
spend more time in conversation they're
happier they're closer they're just all
these different things you know
appreciation love you can only
experience those things in in real life
you know real life conversation smell
matters look matters tone matters
everything matters and like the the
opportunity for nuance in the digital
world is just so de minimis now I
respect the fact that you know people
who feel things strongly and they want
to share a voice that they should I mean
you know they should or they certainly
should be able to I mean Who am I to
sort of make a call on that but what I
will say I remember when you and I
connected around Christmas this year
I was doing one of I do these crazy
train trips you know yeah I want to hear
about this like this is like a tradition
with you every year yeah take a train
cross-country by yourself yeah it's um
you know I've gone across the North I've
gone across the middle of the country of
going across the south I was about to go
from LA to New Orleans when you and I
we're connecting and and then I got in a
car and I drove up and I was in Selma
and my calm
you know different places in Louisiana
and I went to Nashville and Virginia and
I talked to people you know I just like
to talk to people and it's just it's
staggering the degree to which you find
it's not I don't even like the word
common ground it's just we're humans and
we connect and in groups do like we'll
bring groups together we brought
together a group in Nashville and you
know we'll do these impromptu things on
the street we did it in New Orleans and
you know humans it's like that have you
seen that um that a Heineken commercial
where they bring these oddball couples
together and let them talk and it's like
that time after time after time so what
I would say is there's a there's a huge
lie in the world right now and that is
that we all hate each other because it's
true that in social media we hate each
other mm-hmm
if you put those exact same people
together in real life they don't hate
each other a different thing which which
to me is that's called reality right
like you're talking about people
together connecting what's the outcome I
can promise you that you'll get a huge
hit rate of success success being
defined by some kind of a emotional
connection to each other and a respect
for each other and I don't care sort of
what their different politics might be
etc I've seen it too many times I just
know what I'm saying is true so that
leaves does that leave you optimistic
for the future
I mean somewhat I do believe that I mean
if you watch what the health like I did
last night it's hard to be optimistic
but but it's also the case that
pendulums are real you know and that if
you you know I I've heard a lot of
different things I've traveled the
country where some of the people who are
you know they're not on that they're not
on the the good side of the political
world at the moment but nonetheless you
know they're the donations they're
getting and the support they're getting
in the rally that's happening you know
I'm not taking a side and I it sounds
like I'm taking upside because I'm
really not but I do think in struggle
it's often where you find solutions
right how do you speak to your kids
about the use of the mobile device it's
a battle I just lose you know my wife's
really good at it and she's really good
at sort of just turning them off but I'm
a wimp and I and I'm I'm as addicted as
anybody else I'm no I'm another like
super good guy on this having said that
I do I don't get up I don't let myself
get upset and as I mentioned you have
stopped watching TV but like you I watch
Netflix and things like that I just I
stop watching the news right you know I
used to be a big news person and I'll
never forget like on the cover of the
New York Times
Trump was about to give the State of the
Union and it said Trump to give State of
the Union amidst turmoil and chaos and I
just gotten back from my trip on the
train and the drive and I thought wow I
just went across the whole country I
don't I don't recall seeing either
turmoil or chaos the whole way and I was
in like El Paso and San Antonio in all
these different cities I'm being
tongue-in-cheek
I get it I know what they were saying
but in the real world on the day-to-day
in the street like supermarkets were
filled with food and the traffic seemed
to be flowing and I thought chaos it's
it's kind of in the media world and
where everyone's yelling and screaming
at each other yeah I think that's I
think that's very true so when you show
up in a place like Selma do you have
like there's like a neighborhood project
sort of situation there or do you just
walk the streets gage people a little
bit of both I mean there's a lot of the
latter a lot of the latter where you
just start talking to people you know in
in some ways it's it's like finding a
Center it's like a truth finding thing
and it just makes me feel like a
different person you know it's um I was
down at the Island School which is a
school in the Bahamas beautiful place
beautiful place and I mean the spirit of
it is just astounding and what these
guys have built down there and I was
there for like 20 minutes and I felt so
alive and so optimistic you know and I'm
telling you this story because that'll
carry me for weeks
so these trips carry me for four you
know they really motivate me and they
they make me really optimistic and they
they connect me to I don't know who we
are and who we can be in more stories to
tell when you reached out to me at
Christmastime when we were going back
and forth you said yeah I'm gonna do
this train thing I do it every year and
it's my way of really just taking a beat
to get really clear and go deep on what
it is that I want to express in my life
like it's a it's a major timeout that
you have to create boundaries around so
I think that's really cool it's
something that you know most people
don't think about I certainly haven't
done anything like that I've done
different versions of that but I think
that there's you know to actually get on
a train you know in a very tactile and
symbolic way like you're saying like
okay this is I'm gonna go on literally
going on this journey to you know
connect with myself in a new and
different way so how many years have you
been doing that well so I don't know if
you know this but I drove across country
Mike between junior and senior year and
you know if you remember this in kite in
high school and I've driven back and
forth
nine times I've done it on the
motorcycle as well I I'm a motorcycle
person and then I started doing the
Train I used to take my motorcycle to
Florida I would take the auto train down
and that's when I kind of got the bug so
it's probably been like six years that
I've done that now and I still do it
randomly and I've done it the West Coast
like I was here a couple months ago when
I took it I had to go to Santa Fe New
Mexico I took it to Santa Fe so I'll
take it on these random legs as well I'd
like a few weeks ago I had to go to New
Orleans I was in Miami so I flew to
Atlanta I got on the train and then you
know it's about a 12 hour train ride
from there and I took the train to New
Orleans so I'm kind of doing it all the
time right and you know look you're
gonna meet people on the train or nice
period like it's just a different flow
like no security you know someone's in a
hurry
taking Southwest from yeah LA to Vegas
or something and are you do you have
like a are you like journaling or like
these they're like a methodology to how
you kind of approached these excursions
yeah to a certain extent so I I do this
is my daily uh-huh so I do this um this
is my notebook and I'll do like you know
this is today right
gratitude thoughts you know I'll do that
everyday and the nice thing about this
you know there's one page for every day
right so I got to fill up every page or
something's wrong and if I miss a day
I'll do too but I do have a variety of
things and I don't stick to it I mean
other than things like this and I have
some books I read every day
no it's random you know look out the
window shoot I like to shoot you know
film and and I'll get on the computer
and work - yeah yeah so I've never
attended a Nantucket project event but
I've seen plenty of the videos and the
obvious comparison is always going to be
Ted because you know the standard bearer
for these sorts of events but I feel
like there's a there's a conscious
intention in what you do with Nantucket
project to make it more intimate all the
speakers are in the center it's sort of
a theater in the round kind of set up
there's only like what like six hundred
people that attend it's not this massive
thing and so there's a and it seems like
there's a very collegial kind of
community oriented sensibility about the
whole thing that is fostering people to
connect in a way that maybe can't occur
at an event as large as something like
Ted yeah is that accurate you know I
yeah I would say so I mean so I went to
the first Aspen ideas festival which was
I think oh three I had a designer at
Nantucket nectars when I was doing the
anti connectors and a designer told me
about Ted and I just became like a TED
junkie mhm
early 90s he I said go sign us up let's
go then he brought me the bill and I was
like we are not going I had no idea it
cost that much money but it's always
something that's
you know it's always fascinating me I
love to sit and have people kind of
deliver I don't know curiosity and
meaning and there's pressure you know
there's pressure there's a little bit of
energy to a live thing but like anything
else you know it it's I wanted something
a little bit different you know I was
very hungry for something that was a
little bit come at it from a different
angle than the other guys do and I'm
trying to be respectful for of these
other organizations because I am
respectful I think what they do is great
I love and my team we all love you know
like that live wire that is breathing in
real-time
like right in front of you and and in
that regard I the one thing I say about
us here's what I say the other guys know
and we don't like we don't know you know
we want to really come at it from a
point of view of not knowing and and and
let people share and then give them time
to talk - we do we do it as you said we
do it in the round for a reason if you
sit there and you know you're sitting
there and you're watching this person
deliver or it's a film or it's art or
it's music and then across from you can
see all these faces and you know it's
cool it's cool the way that it's it
feels interactive I mean who was it was
it Lawrence Lessig whether you had an
artist on stage who was like drawing you
know sort of creating a visual
representation yeah this amazing talk
that he was giving so it sort of invites
the attendees in to it in a different
way yeah I feel like how did you like
from sort of inception of this idea to
like what it is today I mean you have
like these incredible people that come
and speak like how did you like manifest
that it's good you know here's the thing
and and you know this it's all just hard
work we will make the thirty-sixth phone
call mmm you know well then if we have
to make the thirty-seventh will make the
thirty-seventh
it's been hard hard work just work work
work and and that's really the answer I
mean I there have been times you know
people still ask me I'll be at the nan
at the Nantucket project and people will
say what else you doing these days Tom
one one week of the year I mean come on
right right but but I you know there
came a time a few years ago where I was
I said to myself this is all I'm gonna
do I am just gonna do this I'm gonna
work every day all day to get there and
that's what our team does you know they
just work really hard and and you know
look words we've been talking about
words I say the words to people you know
we say we want you to give the talk your
life we want you to tell it to tell the
story that only you know we want you to
be right there and to give this
vulnerable authentic talk and most
people roll their eyes which I would too
I'd be I'd think who is this idiot like
what are you talking about it for you
know I've heard all this stuff before
but the good news is you know it's eight
years people can see it now and they can
react to it and it's starting to gather
a life you know it's starting to gather
life and and and I think people are
starting to see how and why what we do
is its own thing you know like a podcast
you know or a book I think about a book
is a book could be just about anything
right just imagine all the different
kinds of books you could read well so
can a gathering you know gathering can
be anything it could be any kind of
thing it's interesting I remember when
we were in the juice business everyone
knows how to make radio ads everyone
will tell you how to make you radio ads
you should do this you should do that
why didn't you do this do more of that
and in my business it's like Dana
everyone knows who to book and I always
think would you ever you know I don't
care who the writer is we do go up and
saying write this now like you wouldn't
do that but I understand it I'm gonna if
you thought yeah it's sort of like
understanding the rules and then knowing
where to diverge from them if you follow
the Booker's advice then your events
gonna be like every other event right if
you follow the radio ad guy your ads
gonna be like every other ad
then that may work on a certain level
but it's never gonna allow you to kind
of transcend and break the mold to do
something new and interesting yeah yeah
I think that's cool I think you had said
something I listened to your the first
episode of your podcast and you were
talking about look when you make juice
this is a consumer product they take it
and they consume it and that's the end
of that and now your product is an idea
right and so somebody consumes it but
then they share it and there's a
transformative aspect of that that lives
in breeze you know potentially forever
as a result of that and how you think
about how you produce and share those
two very different types of products
yeah yeah I mean that that story I was
telling you about the the woman I met in
Oakland
every person takes stories to different
places and when you see it in groups
because now we have all these groups
that are you know they're growing all
over the country now they make their own
thing out of it it has nothing to do
with us after I mean literally you go
and you watch and you hear and you see
and you say my god they're making it
into anything they want to make it into
which is great you know you know and in
that regard I was always someone who
believed like there's a mountain top
over there and I got to get to it and as
I'm getting older I'm realizing that
there's not one you just keep going
right yeah because I mean when it I want
to get into the defended Divinity School
stuff in a minute but just on that
thought I think a lot of people would
think in the wake of selling Nantucket
nectars like hey man like I'm good now
like you don't you don't really have to
do anything you know I would imagine
there had to have been at least some
period of time in which you're like okay
I'm going to chill right but at some
point you realize like well you know I
gotta do something with my life right
and you make this decision to kind of
invest yourself in media at that time I
mean what was that what was that period
like for you I would imagine it would
probably be relatively dis
yeah well I mean you know when I go back
to plum and the transition I made coming
out of juice that was you know you know
it's kind of like when the that this is
ridiculous what I'm about to say but for
me personally what I'm about to say is
true when the wall went it came down and
the Soviet Union disappeared like the
the power dynamics changed so
drastically that the world's never been
the same since you know and it's and in
my own little self when when we sold the
anti connectors the power dynamic just
totally changed I mean my job everyday
was to survive and thrive survive and
thrive survive and thrive and if you
remember like right towards the end of
Nantucket nectars Odwalla had those
deaths you remember yeah yeah yeah I
took that whole company down I know and
I see those guys to this day but I tell
the story because I I would people would
say like when was the time where you
realize you made it I never not one time
like never ever did I feel like I we
were in a position where everything's
okay so you just wait after the sale
well after well so you fight like a dog
and then even after the sale it took
like I don't know six months or a year
you think oh my god it's not in my hands
anymore like somebody else is taking
care of this but but there was a massive
vacuum that was left in me and and it
was the hardest time of my life because
suddenly you had you were confronted
with yourself or from what about yeah
yeah I mean I think I'm you know I was
always willing to work hard Tom first my
co-founder at Nantucket nectars and the
team they were just an incredible team
we worked really hard and I don't know I
worked and and I let me just say I
worked 95 percent of the time and then I
partied the other five percent of the
time so there was never I had no balance
I didn't know who I was I was just a guy
on a mission all day every single day
and in a way I probably had some kind of
Arrested Development of variety of ways
and the other thing that happened is you
know this was around 2000 when
you know everyone wanted to give you
money for something and they started to
worship entrepreneurs that's that's the
other thing like that was not very
beginning of yeah yeah and and that
people would invite us to everything and
praise us and write about us we were on
Oprah and the Today Show and all these
things and you know a lot of that is
just false I mean there's really kind of
nothing to that but there's so many
people who think if I could just do that
like that would be it yeah so what is
the what is the message that you would
impart to that person you know what the
bummer is I think you've got a crack
they're gonna crash into their wall to I
you know I wish I could say that was you
know no one gets out of out of life
alive yeah and I you know if the
imbalances are coming back they're
coming you know you're gonna you're
gonna face up to them at some point and
I faced up to them I started to believe
I'll never forget when I was raising
money I'd go to meetings I say you know
I'm trying to raise four million this
what would you do with eight could you
do something with twenty I mean like
that kind of thing when you hear that
you just I know I'm much more interested
in 2010 to well and and that can screw
with your ego and and I got to tell you
like the innocence with which we went
about Nantucket nectars it was real like
it was real real and I don't think to
this day I'm a business person it's not
when I am at my heart I'm like a product
person or an idea person I just love
that and if I haven't if I'm not
matching those two things so forget it
don't don't put me in charge you know
and I didn't know that then I you know I
I think you you you look at other
businesspeople and you say oh I could be
one of those I could do that and you
don't even realize what it is you did
like I being a business person wasn't my
thing being a juice guy whatever that
meant right Ana meant something that's
like what I was like Doug Evans yeah you
know yeah actual friend Doug Evans you
know he's a juice guy ya know and he's
an idea guy and he's a product guy and
and maybe an and and a business guy I
guess but like probably that that isn't
at the top of that list right you know
well and I think in the end I am a
person there's a lot of people like me
there's nothing unique about me
who can get really excited about making
something that doesn't exist for me and
the people I'm with and can organize
something around it that is valuable but
you know money for example like hey I
never thought I'd get wealthy and in the
juice business I just never honestly I
mean later I did I'll never forget I was
driving down the road I had one of those
old flip phones phone rings guys on the
phone hey Tom I want to talk to you
about buying your company and I said I
we're not for sale
well we don't sell the company cuz you
don't want to even hear the number and I
said okay you want to say number say
number and he said a number and it
floored me I mean it was 30 times more
than I thought literally like I had no
idea and I just for sale for the right
number well I
it did change my view of sort of what
these things were I just didn't know I I
thought the way to make money in life is
to have a big salary mm-hmm right and we
were making like thirty five thousand
dollars a year each so I don't know I
just thought this is funny yeah
so now when you go to the store or you
go to Chipotle or whatever and you see
the Nantucket nectars in the in the
refrigerated case like what is your
emotional response to that it's pretty
zero is it I am very well says Tom and
Tom on the back it's a little story
about you guys and all that I feel very
disconnected from it you know it's we
had a thing and and you know it's all
fine I don't get emotional about it but
we had a thing called the quality juice
evolution solution which meant we would
make any flavor better when we could I
could bore you with examples but 100%
lemon juice not from concentrate you
know on and on different apples and they
don't do that and I just it's okay you
don't have to do that but it's just so
different that I don't even connect with
it right once you sell it yeah it's an
entirely different thing every now and
get my kids will bring it up okay dad
isn't that york juice oh my god yeah
yeah do you know uh do you know Jimmy
from evolution evolution Jeff's
no he's a great guy that's the one
that's Starbucks right
Starbucks bought it yeah he's actually
having a romance with them like because
they they build a huge facility for him
and they've maintained you know he's in
like Doug he's insane about quality and
they've been able to kind of live up to
that promise so he's super happy but his
first juice company I think I hope I'm
not getting this wrong but I think it
was naked and then they sold that and it
was not like it just the quality
everything changed and you know he had
you know he kind of had like an
existential crisis in the heck of that
you know in that regard Doug Evans like
crushed it from a quality perspective I
mean what he was doing putting those
vegetables fruits and vegetables
together in those packs that's hard like
this is hard hard hard stuff I mean talk
about pushing a rock up a hill like what
he you know look he's our friend
I love Doug we were talking about this
before the podcast and it's it was
painful to see what happened to him
because his heart is so huge and his
vision was so gigantic and he got
crushed by virtue of never being able to
control the narrative around juice arrow
being a victim of whatever this
journalist or that journalist decided to
say and from from the get-go from the
very first New York Times article there
was a decision that was made in the kind
of general consciousness that this was
going to be emblematic of Silicon Valley
excess and from day one they never were
able to recover from that because they
couldn't figure out how to tell the
story that you and I both know which is
that it was about the infrastructure and
the logistical systems that they were
setting up that was going to
revolutionize how we were going how are
you're getting food farm-to-table yeah
it wasn't just an expensive machine it
was so much more than that but they
couldn't really translate that story in
a meaningful way and the whole thing
just cratered and it breaks my heart and
I talked to Doug all the time I know you
talked to him and you know he's a
survivor and he'll he's going to end up
doing something amazing in the future
but but to see him crushed
that system was was difficult it's hard
you know I always say the the the
greatest juice company ever will be the
people who invent the teleporter because
if you really want good juice you are in
the field where the stuff is picked and
you squeeze it right in front of
yourself and you consume it and you know
with no pasteurization and no other sort
of forms of preservatives and if you
wind your way back from that you're this
is a major major challenge and I got
nothing against it but all the people
who use HPP I you know I don't I don't
drink it I got nothing against it you
know Nantucket nectars uses like a
regular you know
UHT or different kinds of pasteurization
but fresh is fresh and fresh is the best
and fresh is so hard and what Doug was
doing closest thing in the world to it
and it wasn't about that juicer that
machine it was about those packs those
packs were really hard to make and they
were doing it and and they had they had
prototypes for a component odor ly
compostable compostable pack and they
had a prototype for a new machine that
would press twice as much juice twice as
fast at half the cost of the original
machine so it was just a they had it was
it was a time it was like they were
running they ran out of time because
scale can deliver the price point that
the market would have celebrated rather
than yeah it's it's kind of the only
thing I mean like any other innovation
or almost any other innovation the it's
really expensive in the beginning it's
hard to make it at the right margin but
they were on their way and you know so
now you're left with your juicer at home
and when you raise 250 million dollars
or whatever they rate you know it's a
different they're playing in a different
I feel completely yeah and there's a lot
of good reasons for it it but it is sort
of a shame and and I really admire
Doug's willingness to do this and all
these guys all these people who are
trying to make these fresh you know
again that good wall I think when people
die because that's what happens when
you're playing with fresh it's hard
you know you got to work like hell to
figure out the way to do the teleporter
to make to get the fruit or the
vegetable fresh-squeezed right to you
and you know my wife bless her she does
it in the machine and she cleans up and
she does all the stuff I don't have the
patience for I know but it is
interesting that that like Nantucket
nectars was the first wave like the
first introduction of like hey you know
you can have something a little bit
different than you're used to that's a
little bit healthier it has these
different flavors and now to see what is
transpired in the 20 years since then
with all these new iterations on healthy
juice it's like the more feel like you
know at the time even in the success of
Nantucket nectars I remember thinking
like well how many juice companies can
there be yes right like where is this
gonna end like this there's got to be
market saturation and clearly not
because look what has happened it's gone
way crazy thus light passes it's not
even close it's amazing it really is
amazing I mean even you know again back
to the film I saw last night or all this
stuff you know Kip vessels tin and all
these people I've been studying a lot
through you know through you you know in
the early days of Nantucket nectars
where do you sell it you saw it to
health food stores which means they
don't pay their bills very well mm-hmm
the stores gonna be a little messy and
poorly managed like that was that's the
nature these are like hippies and a
dream and now hippies in a dream like
Amazon just bought it from Whole Foods
and it's just a whole different world
and it's come a long long way and you
know people like you who were doing I
don't think there was such a thing as
when did ultra marathons or ultra
triathlons I they've been around but
it's sort of been a fringe marginal
thing and now you see like all these
people are running 50k Xand 50-miler
100-mile is like in a way that you know
like when I first heard of it I was like
what oh yeah you didn't nobody talked
about this but there was always been
that subculture but analogous to kind of
the you know marginalized hippie
lifestyle I suppose well let's get back
to storytelling a little bit I II I
remember that you we had a little
communication it must have been 2008
maybe and you reached out to me and we
were connecting
a number of things and you're like oh
hey like I'm working on this TV show
thing and it's with these brothers and I
think you might I think you might like
these guys they're pretty cool like here
watch this little video that this guy
Casey made and you sent me one of his
early videos which was about running a
free what is called like you know it
goes out and runs and that was my very
first introduction to Casey nice that
and you end up becoming you produced not
only their TV show the nice stepbrothers
for HBO but also you produce you
produced daddy-longlegs
yeah also which is with Casey and the
safty bro yes right who recently blown
up yeah what's that movie with the
vampire guy just came out this year I
haven't seen it big-time big-time I
think that was cool I haven't seen it
yet but a lot of he's good talking about
that movie it's a really good guys are
the next thing like the next Tarantino
or whatever so that's an interesting
move in and of itself to go from juice
to like okay I'm getting into movies and
TV so how did you connect with like the
safty Brothers I'm Casey you know it
goes back to a lot of the stuff we've
been talking about here I I have a I
love spirited people like spirited
people on missions is exciting to me
it's just an exciting thing to me and I
I always when I'm around um I feel it
Doug Evans
you know you Casey and Van nice tat the
safty brothers you mentioned a bunch of
others over the years you run into these
people who are on these missions and
when they're on those missions you can
tell they're on these missions you know
they're just like these Casey you know
Casey and van made ads for us mm-hmm
way back when Ford nantucket Nocturna no
forward plumb TV okay and um and I just
thought wow look at these two guys and
so I brought him in my office and I said
I want to make a movie with you
and they you know they said like about
what and I said I don't know I just
you guys have spirit like III want to do
something here and they said all right
well let us get something together I
said okay so they left and then they
came back I don't know a week later and
they said
how do you feel about a TV series and we
shook hands like within 20 minutes they
had to give they had to turn in a new
episode every six weeks for a year and I
said all the only I ask is this is the
only thing you do for the next year and
that we don't try to sell it until we're
done like make eight because I know you
guys are you know crazy crazy in all the
best ways and we did and we and it was
all I can think is that when I met those
two guys
I mean artistically they're really great
but their spirit is out of this world
and I thought that spirit is going
somewhere and I want to work with him to
figure out what it is and so we did and
it was a great journey we we we took the
I had a friend at HBO and I said I got
to show you something I know you're
gonna like this and then she washed it
and she said you're right come in I said
okay so we went in and we walked out and
within an hour there they said we want
the whole thing right and it was that
fast yeah it's crazy and what's
interesting about it if you go back and
watch it
it's the fidelity like you could eat
it's you know what Casey does now is
certainly refined in terms of technique
but it's the same thing yeah it's like
he was vlogging basically you know in
that show and doing it you know years
before anybody else was it's like you
know and now to see his trajectory I
mean it's insane just past like nine
million subscribers on YouTube I mean
arguably one of the most influential
people of art of our generation
certainly in terms of youth culture I
know it's it's it's quite something and
that it's that spirit you know it's a
key to very focused driven and
intentional about what he does in a way
that I think you only know when you're
around and when the cameras off and you
could see like there's no mistakes like
he knows exactly what he's doing
yeah well in he's um he's gonna die for
his country I mean he's he's going for
it and that then there's just no doubt
about it and his courage his creative
courage is outrage
yeah it's outrageous I mean have you
seen that the Laird Hamilton documentary
no I haven't seen it yet a bunch of
people tell me it's good you got to
watch that because it doesn't make sense
the choices like the choices don't make
sense
there is no box you put this stuff in
and then that's what model there's no
like if you want to do this this is the
road that you follow they're creating
their own road there's no road it makes
no business sense create it just doesn't
make sense I mean you've really got to
into fiction and vision and courage yeah
yeah and and that's you know one of my
sons just loved Casey stuff and hey and
he's you know he has some element of
that enemy just thinks about it all day
and he just so believes in it I have to
say I got great influence as far as I'm
concerned like what a keep at it like do
your thing um it's I think about Casey
all the time in my own career I mean
there's a lot of times I'm sure you've
experienced this you don't know where
this is going you know and and those
things where you just do it and you hope
and you correct and you do it again and
you do it because you feel it you know
you feel that thing where you know like
oh there's something special going on
here
that's the thing about Laird Hamilton I
mean you you some of the choices that he
was making as an example he just didn't
like competitions mmm because they are
boring right yeah
no his his competition is with himself
it doesn't have anything to do with
anybody else and here it turns into like
this I don't know is it a movement I
don't know what it is I'm talking about
Laird I mean it's like its own sport
it's it's own thing is it sport is it
art is it is it just a manifestation of
one person's you know life and yeah
passion you know but there is there's it
take it takes an incredible amount of
courage to step outside that box when
there's money to be made and Fame to be
had by doing it the way your
predecessors have done it so that so
that bliss thing the Joseph Campbell
thing were we talking about since we sat
down you know one of the like slow-mo
you turned me on to slow-mo rights
and the beauty of that whole thing is
when he says the guy in the hospital
says do what you want and the critical
thing in that whole equation is you got
to know what that is you know the the
the the one I'm when it's 2001 and I've
sold Nantucket nectars I had no idea
what that was so you you tell me to do
what I want it's gonna be destructive
mm-hmm it was yeah I know that's but
then you have this place where you know
you gonna they take in Jos you know in
the hero's journey you go into the woods
and when you go into the woods you're
going into a woods where there's no path
no path no path and can you be guided by
your bliss so you got to know what it is
and gotta the courage to go and in order
to know what it is you have to be a
fully integrated human being otherwise
you're gonna be victim to your baser
desires yeah or you're gonna be you know
chasing the wrong thing thinking it's
the goal that you aspire to when in fact
it isn't
that's what Casey does yeah in Casey but
he knows who he is like he's very
connected to what that is and he's
fearless in his pursuit of that and I
think that that's that's extremely rare
but when you are exposed to it it's
infectious you know and so as somebody
who's around a lot of amazing people you
can't help by nothing other than osmosis
to absorb some of that and allow it to
you know fuel your own courage I think
yeah well and I think those you know
there's a couple times over the last say
10 years where two times in particulars
people offered me jobs and I've never
really had a job where I worked for
someone else why I did when I was a kid
but you know in each case I said well
how much will I get paid and in both
cases I thought whoa I just you know
I've I've never made that kind of salary
in my life and especially when it wasn't
me coming up with the money you know
like you're gonna pay me and I don't
have to worry about where you're gonna
get that money from and uh and in both
cases I had like a 24-hour period I
thought I'm gonna do this this is great
like I this is perfect I don't have to
worry about this I have to worry about
that
I have some money and thank God I mean I
think about people like Casey and I
think I can't do that I cannot do that
but um you know I I go on that roller
coaster and I get afraid and tempted and
all these different things
that's why slow-mo when he does what he
wants he actually knows and it's a
little it's out there well I'm the the
the amazing thing about that is that
it's so simple like when he really
thought about like what he wanted to do
the dude just wanted to rollerblade
right and that's it and I think as human
beings we want to complicate it like
well I want this but I kind of want that
too and maybe if I do that I can do that
and you know one of the reasons I love
slo-mo and I feel so connected to him is
because I had a very similar impulse
when I was having this like existential
crisis I was like what what makes me
happy like what do I want to do and it
you know I was thinking like career or
like how am I gonna get out of being a
lawyer like I just felt like I was in
prison I was like I just like you know I
like what it feels like when I jump in a
swimming pool you know I like how I feel
when I'm on that trail at dawn and it's
kind of chilly and the Sun pops up over
the ridge and I can feel it on my back
and I can and all I can hear is my
breath mmm like that's that's what I
loved what was then so I just started
doing that because I wanted to connect
with that part of myself that I felt I
had ignored and had lost it's not a
business plan it's not a it's not a life
plan but it is part and parcel of that
movement towards becoming more fully
integrated how conscious was that kind
of moment or choice and and did it
involve something like I'm gonna do this
race or this competition no no it was
nothing like that I mean it event it
evolved into that but initially it was
like I'm so disillusioned and I'm so
despondent over these choices that I've
made about my life and how I invest my
time
and I can't do it anymore and I don't
know what the exit strategy is but I
know that my only path forward is to
start engaging with these impulses that
I have about how I want to spend my time
so your commitment or decision or
whatever you want to call it to let that
lead you one was it was it was that
conscious like I'm going to let this
lead me somewhere I think initially if
it wasn't it was just I don't care it
was more about like I don't care what
the ramifications are or if this is
gonna cost me a heart cause problems in
my life like I just feel like I need to
do this so it began with that and then
it became once I once it sort of kicked
in I was like I'm gonna cook I'm gonna
continue to pursue this thread wherever
it may lead me and that may mean I
always continue to be a lawyer wait you
know I just I didn't know there was no
clarity at all it was just what am i
doing today and then waking up the next
day and like how am I gonna spend my
time so has vast day changed everything
absolutely and has it changed for the
good without a without a doubt and is
there something mystical in that or
whatever the word is in other words is
it a part of what I'm asking is like do
you believe this you want every part of
what you just said
I believe it but I also have because
it's a story that I've told so often I
worry that I lose my connection with the
truth of it yeah you know and so for me
I have to make a conscious effort effort
to really like revisit it as honestly as
I possibly can because I want to answer
you as honestly as I can it's that thing
where when you look back in retrospect
it seems like it all lined up
perfectly but in the midst of it it was
extremely confusing I didn't have
clarity about it and I would like to say
oh I was on this spiritual mission
certainly it was mystical because it
doesn't make sense in a rational heat
away and there was plenty of doubt along
the road where I thought I was losing
the plot and that I was being foolish
and I was certainly reminded by many
people that I was and so it - minded
what I'm sorry sorry like what you know
why what do you doing oh I see you know
it like what why are you doing this you
should be doing this you know I heard a
lot of that and I have to credit my wife
who always was like you know who's who's
always been my teacher in this regard
who's like listen you know the the
resolution to the pain that you're
suffering the growth that you seek the
path forward you can't shortcut it and
the only way to gain the clarity and to
actualize in the way that you're seeking
is to follow this thread and see it
through and whatever happens like I have
your back so there was a lot of
financial turmoil there was a lot of you
know that we it was hard man you
know for a long time but it was that
conviction that I couldn't I couldn't
have had that on my own like it was her
support that allowed me to kind of
maintain the course so when I look back
now it's like it's insane it's insane
that I'm sitting here having a
conversation with you today like my life
is changed in every conceivable fashion
and I can't attribute that to anything
other than the mystical aspect of what
it means to connect with yourself as a
spiritual being having a physical
experience yeah well you know the I
don't even know what this means and I
mean that but I have I have like ah I
pray right if you ask me to who or I
could bore you with an answer but but I
pray and and one of the things I've
discovered through that is that I
I pay a lot attention to what I ask for
you know because I feel the way you feel
I mean I look back and I think and I
mean I've been in bankruptcy court like
I've been through some stuff you know
I've had a crazy road I'll take my road
all day long a lot of people deal with
things much worse but my road is not
some straight happy-go-lucky road a lot
of pain a lot of pain but the most clear
thing I can hope for is that I can
continue to be useful right and I have
to be open to the fact that I don't know
exactly what that means right so I can I
can buy my store you were talking about
your story I can buy my story and if I'm
praying for my story I'm off something's
wrong I'm too invested in this story and
not enough into sort of like what is the
spark of the thing that's motivating you
in the first place and be open to the
fact that it can change it's not gonna
always be the same so every now and
again I find myself Sam
I just sort of speaking of the world and
saying how can I be the most useful to
the world and I feel better when I'm
doing that because it's a little scary
to say that because I want to deliver I
want to deliver for my business I want
to deliver for the people I work with I
want to uncover some things and grow
some things and discover some things
that I just feel crazy about but I got
to be open to the fact that I don't know
what where the path is and I think you
can get to places where you think like
ah okay now I got the path you're like
oh and and release your your pressure on
the gas but I think in my experience
when you are in that mentality and
practice of service how can I be useful
to others how can I give of myself
freely that that is the way to get
clarity and resolution on all the other
things that you're confused about you
know and that is mystical on its own
right because it doesn't make sense yeah
but that has proven true in in my life
many times over yeah yeah me too
so what sorry go ahead well I was just
gonna say I I learned that when I'm on
as much as I'm off mmm I've been off
plenty of times
right well yeah when you're off and then
you know you get the universe you know
like slaps you across the face and you
get the reminder yeah what was the
impetus to to go to defend Divinity
School you know so III I'm at least 50
percent believing that there's more to
this story you know I was reading I was
rereading is that in the art of
motorcycle maintenance I read it in 1988
and I read it again in like 2011 or
something like that maybe 12 and I was
reading a brief history of time at the
same time same time reading those two
books and you know ii read zen and the
art however many years later i don't
want to do the math 20-some years later
which but totally different book I
couldn't believe what I was reading I
thought I've already read this how's
that possible as I was reading it I
thought
and by the way Stephen Hawking opens the
book and by saying I'm gonna tell you
everything that's happened since the Big
Bang and I don't know what happened
before and so I'm like aha you just left
the door open but as the stories we're
weaving together and you're learning
about the nature of time and and gravity
and all these different things and then
you're you know you're reading about you
know what is a quality they talk a lot
about quality and Zen in the art it was
amazing the way the two stories wove
together and I just again I think
there's a better than 50% chance that
there's more to the story like there's
there are things out there that we just
have no idea about and I thought Here I
am however old I was 45 48 years old and
I don't know him much about it I don't
know anything about it
so I thought gosh to have the
opportunity you know yells not that far
down the road from me and I had the time
then I had the time then go learn like
go dive in go see and you know I always
find it's this interesting dividing
point I say to somebody
or they find out I'm in Divinity School
a lot of people they don't wanna talk to
me you know they want to leave it that
big and then other people are super
curious about it and and you know I
don't know what I am I don't know what I
believe but I believe you know so if you
ask me like for example I'm a Joseph
Campbell person generally I mean it's
sort of like he's sort of the guy who
has probably opened my eyes more than
anybody else and it's a lot about sort
of pointing like you know stories point
you to places but in and of themselves
they're not answers per se they just
sort of enlighten you to possibilities
of getting answers but if you think
about sort okay for example the story of
Jesus by the way very controversial dude
you there's there's there are certain
words you can't say for example at the
Nantucket project not because we have a
list of rules but because this is how
humans are today Jesus used to be on the
list and then people started to talk
about it very taboo word very
interesting word anyway I don't know if
I think there's that that story is true
and that he is the son of God and that
mary is his mother and mary you know was
a virgin and gave birth to this guy but
if you read the story and you can be in
the story and you can learn from the
story I believe in that and I don't know
if that makes sense but so when people
ask more like do you believe that Jesus
is the Son of God I say at a minimum I
kind of believe in the story of it I can
I can take a lot from that story but you
know I've studied Buddhism and I've
studied lots of things so I can take
that in a lot of different stories but I
won't jump up and down say this for that
or the other thing is not true because
yeah I don't know well this is the stuff
of life this is perhaps the most
fascinating subject matter that grapples
with what it means to be alive and be
human
yeah and it's weird that we're in a time
where the pursuit of trying to better
understand these myths in these
traditions and these religions that have
defined us as a species is somehow sort
of stigmatized or you
makes people think that you're weird for
wanting to do that because is there
anything more magical and fascinating
and and and and truly important because
it's asking the question like what is
the best way to be a human and how can
you be happy and how can you give of
yourself and be fulfilled and and find
meaning in this short time that we share
on earth and I think when you look at
the story of Jesus it's like you know
set aside son of God you know all of
that it's like this guy was a radical
revolutionary who spoke truth to power
in a time where it was very dangerous to
do that amidst a culture of very
oppressed people in a specific part of
the world and that was revolution I mean
this guy was like hardcore victim now
and the more you learn if you just look
at it and evaluate it from a pure
historical perspective you know in just
a position to you know the controlling
forces in that area of the planet at
that time it's fascinating
amazing you know ya know you are you uh
familiar with Rob Bell know pastor Rob
Bell former mega church pastor who broke
ranks and and really has reinvented
himself as as a deep thinker and an
interesting thinker about Christian
traditions he's a remarkable amazing
human being and he's become a friend
spent on the podcasts coming back on
Friday there's a brand new documentary
about him that is going to be premiering
on Amazon and iTunes on Thursday it's
called The Heretic you should definitely
check it out by the time this airs for
the audience listening it will be
available on Julie and I were able to go
to the premiere the other day and it's
it's it's a very interesting look at a
man who who took a different position on
how he looks at the story of Jesus and
how it's been co-opted
by our culture and has spoken openly and
publicly about this at great personal
peril like it just basically you know it
destroyed his life and he's been he's
had to rebuild it in a new and
interesting way and when he talks he's
got a podcast called the broadcast you
should check that out as well but I
think he would find it super interesting
my my when I got to Yale so the one
thing I didn't mention was um recovery
right you know there's a big chunk of
people in this world who are healthy and
in recovery by virtue of programs that
have God at the center of them right and
a lot of them are people who didn't have
God in the center of anything right a
lot of them and you know we were talking
believe like do you believe the story of
your commitment to running and the
choices that you made and where it
brought you and in a similar vein I
would ask the same thing about
spirituality and like the you know it's
relationships or twelve steps and you
know you go in these rooms and you get
these people who a lot of them I think
we're like the opposite of any part of
that world right we know these people
and then they get this spiritual
connection and they might turn into like
incredibly beautiful happy giving
positive members of our culture
you know like incredible and then you
ask the question like well they say that
God is part of what got him there do
they believe that like do they really
embrace that and what are they talking
about when they talk about God what do
they mean what is spiritual mean you
know people say I'm spiritual not
religious what does that actually mean
so that was a lot of what took me there
you know that was a lot of what guide me
and how do you answer that question well
I just you know to me it is a it's kind
of what I said you before like I believe
there's way more to this story and I'll
never know what it is
but I am perfectly content seeking and
contemplating it throughout and then
practicing certain things in my life and
see what it does for me and for my
family and to the people around me I
mean my family
is as big a benefactor of my attempt to
be healthy then anymore of course yeah
it's like so I can say it's about me and
on a certain level is about me but they
live much better lives when I'm you know
seeking some of these different kinds of
things so that's kind of my answer and
it's part of what drew me to school but
the thing I was gonna say is when I got
there you know my first class was well
my first class was does God exist and
fascinating stood you know write 14
proofs for God not God 3 prove not got
11 prove God and it's just really
interesting to walk through them I
couldn't recite them back to you but I
was my mind was blown but then I took um
Old Testament and my Old Testament
professor was a guy named joel baden
who's a friend now best teacher I've
ever had of any kind just brilliant
brilliant guy well he's a Jewish
non-believer mm and you know it's really
interesting and I don't know what I was
when I walked in there and I don't know
what I am now and I mean that sincerely
I'm open to sort of lots of different
things but really interesting to walk
into what I expected to be like a
believing Christian who is sort of
touting certain things to sort of lay
that out and I walk away from that more
than anything else not knowing but but I
do sort of you know so when people say I
don't like religion and Dogma
well that's dogma it's a thesis it's its
own version it's own version of dogma so
I don't know where I am on the spiritual
not religious thing I just don't know I
don't even know what people say when
they mean when they say that and I'm
okay you know done yoga for years and
I'm not doing it now but I did it for
many years and I'd go along with the
Nama stays and all this stuff and get
into the God and was I believing was I
religious was I spiritual I don't know I
was just enjoying it what is the
composition of the student body in that
program like other I would assume
there's people there who want to be
priests yeah yeah there's sort of
average people like you know sort of
yeah just academic minded people like
yourself there's all of the above I mean
it's very
I'm kind of fascinated by the people who
have been believers their whole lives
you know it's and there's lots of them
you know or to a certain extent I mean
that's one of the things like this woman
Nadia Bowles whoever who like broke the
Jesus barrier at the Nantucket project
really fascinating woman would amaze you
bro what does that mean well she so she
stood she gave a benediction at the
Nantucket project and I'm not gonna read
she was the first person to use she's
Jesus yeah and she said she said
something like say a benediction was
like blessed are the crack
blessed are the strong outshot I mean
this woman is a woman who's been in
recovery and she's a she's a Lutheran I
think a Lutheran and um I don't remember
I was going with the story but but she
broke the book the Jesus about this
powerful yeah yeah but uh you know I
could like the idea that this guy hung
around prostitutes and did all these
different things and then when you read
the Old Testament from the perspective
of someone who's a non-believer but a
brilliant guy who knows a cult it's it's
like a free-for-all you know they're
sleeping with your brother and your
sister and this guy's wife and it's it's
going to the violence I mean it's a
crazy book these books are intense did
you read did you study the Bhagavad Gita
also is there just a critic there's a
Christian tradition it program it's all
there it's it's all there and I I have
been not in depth right um you know I
did a my first semester I did of course
meditation east and west and it was
taught by a woman who's a nun Catholic
nun and uh awesome awesome I mean we're
going you know we're doing Buddhist and
I don't remember like all these
different forms of meditation and going
pretty deep on that while we're
simultaneously doing like different
Catholic traditions like the lectio
divina and all these things I've never
even heard of and the long story short
is like there are these Christian
mystics throughout history who just were
these fascinating people and I'm my
whole point being that I didn't know the
first thing about Christianity when I
got there and I didn't know much about
the other things but they're links and
again it goes back to Joseph Campbell
like he's the guy who actually figured
or one of the people who figured all
this out so how does this that
experience kind of frame your
perspective on your life and you know
what you're trying to express like it
has changed how you approach that to a
certain extent because I think you know
like most people I'm not comfortable
being like thought of as the weirdo but
I know that sort of the meaning I've
taken out of those I mean I got to also
take constitutional law through one of
the Grand best Yale Law School
professors and I took political science
courses and things but you know it's
what I we were talking about Facebook
earlier there's way more to this story I
mean whatever conventional wisdom is at
any given moment is such a small part of
the story and the idea that we're the
first you know era in history to have it
all figured out like forget it that's
just crazy and we'd really we get into
these moments where we think we just
have everything all figured out and I
appreciate Silicon Valley technology and
all these other things as much as
anybody else does but you know at the
same time you got you could talk about
Plato and Aristotle for weeks
and it's a good reminder that all these
things are there like it's a good
reminder to hear your story and that you
know that truth I say truth and that you
kind of said truth I don't I don't know
what I'm gonna say truth which was the
thing that attracted you to sort of
change your life which by the way some
of it was an attraction and some of it
was a I gotta get out of here you know
the ability to connect with that story
is really complicated and really
important like really really really
important and really really really a
gift and it helped me make sense of you
know judgment and I don't mean in a
Jesus sense I just mean you know
I live in a place like where you live
where these people are judged big-time
you know talking about religious people
are judged where I come from and I just
think once you get into the practice of
doing that kind of thing you're going
down a path that you're gonna be the
person who pays the price we all pay a
price for that but it you did a lot to
sort of open me up to that and like work
hard to always be open to the fact that
you may not know what the heck you're
talking about yeah
humility yeah yeah which is hard to
learn hard you know only it's only a
practice right yeah I mean it's
certainly not my default no not me
either
it requires work and awareness to get
there but when you can touch that space
your ability to connect with yourself
and other people is profoundly enhanced
yeah you know I think about depression
like I suffered from depression to two
periods in my life where was most
intense and um you know I was prescribed
Zoloft
wellbutrin propanolol and Valium
all at the same time right I was crazy
crazy as a result of taking those pills
I was probably crazy anyway I'm not
saying I wasn't but I was crazy when I
took those pills and I you know haven't
taken anything in more than a decade I
try to eat well and I don't do any of
that stuff and I'm very happy and
generally I have a peace in my life
generally it can come and go but one of
the things that I've woken up to is now
that there's a lot of stories here so
this is just my story I'm not gonna
people can use any pills they prefer I
think I don't know I'm not taking a
position on that but what I am saying is
lack of humility manifests itself in a
negative focus on yourself in a really
powerful way and I think somehow if I
know I used to interpret a kind of
humility as like don't get too full of
yourself and it turns out no it's
don't think about yourself all the time
and I think my depression was a lot
about that I was a lot about like focus
on myself all day long and negative but
okay yeah and I think that
self-centeredness can take many forms it
can it can take the form of being too
focused on your own self-improvement
yeah you know I mean it that's a
laudable you know sort of perspective
and yet it can still lead you astray
because it's all about you yeah you know
and I think broadening that aperture is
an antidote for a lot of what ails us
but it it's in counterpoint to you know
the marshalling of all of the influences
and stimuli that were exposed to every
day that's telling us to you know get
your own and you know where's mine
and how can I get this quicker and
arrive at the destination sooner mmm and
I think it's making us profoundly
unhappy there was an it have you read
Johann Hari is new book about depression
no should check it out he's did this
massive study interviewed a million
people he was recently on Joe Rogan's
podcast and talked about it for like
three hours was fascinating getting at
the root of what is actually making us
depressed and it's like you said you
sort of alluded to earlier like it's a
much more complicated nuanced thing than
oh you have some brain chemistry that's
a little bit off and if I give you this
cocktail it's going to fix it and again
I'm not saying I have no opinion on the
appropriateness of those medications I
think a lot of people have benefited
from them but I think we're too quick to
prescribe at at the you know while
forsaking all of these other things that
are contributing to this malaise that
we're experiencing as a culture and a
profound and unprecedented way yeah yep
yeah no I agree with all of what you
said all right we got to land this plane
okay but let's let's leave somebody's
gonna fly get down or here at the end to
leave people with a little bit of an
uplifting thing I mean look you've lived
an incredible life man I mean amazing
what you've been able to express an
experience and all these amazing people
as a result of the work you do in the
Nantucket project
if you could take some kernel of wisdom
out of that and impart it to somebody
who is listening to those who maybe is
inspired but is stuck like I just can't
you know I can't break free of this self
created prison that I'm in or I'm in a
job that is not suited to me or I can't
you know whatever it is some mental or
very real-world barrier yeah you know
I'm gonna read something I wrote earlier
belief would be is my general answer
like I asked you you know I asked I feel
very strongly that you found a path
through that Sun on your back on that
run right like I just really really and
every part of my heart believe that and
not one person in the history of time
well maybe they exist cuz I can't that's
a broad statement but nose nose nose
where it's going no one knows you know
and especially in the 90s we've got all
these like entrepreneur this that and
the other thing you meet all these
people the paths are a mess they're all
a mess like there's no perfect path oh
that you know they were great managers
they had a perfect cult no one does no
one did never never happened and so how
do people find their way through they
find that little place that little spark
and and in the end you you gotta have
faith in that you got to believe in that
you got to choose that over all the
other choices and keep going cuz all the
others choices stink you know that and I
I learned all that the hard way I
learned all of that the hard way I
remember when I was in bankruptcy you
know that you go and they lay out your
case and it's pretty harsh you know and
you're sitting there and you can just
tell the judge is like who is this idiot
that we're reading about right now like
what an idiot and then finally he says
um and I'm sitting there hearing all
this readout and the judge says who
is thomas w scott and and i'm like that
is a great frickin question and i mean i
had a moment of clarity I had a moment
of clarity where I was just like yeah
thank you that's a good question and I
but the point is I thought I'd only have
one choice right here and I'm gonna walk
forward and do the very best I can as
I'm going out of this darkness because
there's no other choice there is no
other choice that works now they are
they are there but it's just illogical
like you've learned all these stuff so
just have a moment of faith so in
Episode one of the nice that brother's
van quotes jean-luc Godard and I wrote
it down today for some reason I looked
it up but it says all the dragons and
our lives or perhaps princes princesses
expecting us to be handsome and brave
all the terrifying things are perhaps
nothing but helpless things waiting for
us to help them and it's just you know
everything I've experienced in my life
in all those dragons that kind of sit
there that you think of as these just
horrible things or like the guide it's
that thing kind of waiting for you to
just kind of take that step and to keep
going and in the end like that's the
beauty of the story that's the beauty of
the path you know and it's never you
know when we would go to business
schools like well I still do that but
they lionize you and I sometimes think
like these people gonna go out and and
they're gonna start into the mud and
they're gonna be like what the
happened and then through this little is
that right like like Harvard Business
School dude like a key study on you guys
right oh yeah right that was like yeah
and and that would happen and they would
lionize us I mean I did try as often as
I could to sort of say you know this is
not as right but beneath that like
basically it's a beautiful passage thank
you for reading that I mean what I
gather from that what I get out of that
is is first of all understanding that
that the way we view the world is a
perspective and that perspective is is
malleable
it's shiftable and if you can step
outside your frame and see it from a
different direction it could completely
realign how you navigate your path and
then sort of second to that is this idea
of not trying to avoid obstacles in your
life or or or or this idea that if you
face them that somehow you've failed but
to understand that not only is this part
of it it's inescapable and it should be
welcomed because every obstacle that you
face is your opportunity to grow and
that growth is you know more than your
business is what you're really here to
do yeah yeah and and I would just so
emphasize that I believe in what you
just said like I really believe it I
think the and I say that because I think
often and I do it
it sounds poetic and we take it as
poetry and not like Phaedra yeah and and
just to you know you go you go you just
keep going it's good talking to you man
you too that was awesome that's great
yeah thank you so much
beautiful if people want to connect with
you and your mission what's the best
place nantucket project calm and if
anyone wants to they can write me at Tom
at Nantucket project yeah a lot of
emails and if you want to check out some
of the speakers that you have you guys
have a youtube channel right and you can
see all we do we do and and the
neighborhood project if you want to
start a neighborhood project there in I
don't know like 25 states now that's
cool yeah that's growing it's close
there are website for that or is that
part of Nantucket project calm there's a
neighborhood project part on there we
launched it formally on first day of
spring but it's it's out there and it's
yeah kind of growing organically awesome
and the neighborhood project podcast
yeah three people who knows that well
it's on the web like you texted me hey
like here's a little thing we're we're
I'm really into right now but I
founded on the web I was like okay is
this like he's doing a pocket like you
know so I had already checked it out so
it's uh it's out in the world right yeah
yeah I I mean we are serious rookies at
this but yes it is now ma'am I loved it
people should check it out okay cool now
thanks dude all right peace
[Music]